we begin the day with russia's wish list
for its future dealings with the west
today moscow published a set of security
proposals that aim to limit nato's
expansion into former soviet countries
the documents were handed to the united
states earlier this week president putin
is demanding legally binding guarantees
that nato would give up any military
activity in eastern europe and ukraine
the line pursued by the united states
and nato over recent years
to aggressively escalate the security
situation
is absolutely unacceptable and extremely
dangerous
washington and its nato allies should
immediately stop hostile actions against
our country
including unscheduled war games
dangerous encounters
and maneuvers of military ships and
planes
and stop for military use of ukrainian
territory
nato's leadership and the white house
have indicated that they are open to
talks with russia but they insist that
every country has the right to determine
its own future without outside
interference and the alliance has
rejected what it says amounts to a veto
on its expansion
we have received
russia's recent proposals
we are clear that any dialogue with
russia would also need to address nato's
concerns
about
russia's actions
be based on the core principles
and documents of european security and
take place in consultation with nato's
european partners such as ukraine
well tensions between russia and the
west have soared over a recent build-up
of russian troops near ukraine
triggering fears of an invasion moscow
denies any plan to attack its neighbour
despite mounting evidence to the country
this is some of the latest video from
russia's board of regents shot by a
french television crew about eight
kilometers from ukraine according to the
reporter this normally functions as an
occasional training area for the russian
army but for weeks now they've been
massing troops and equipment essentially
turning it into a military base
so let's take a closer look at these
russian demands and nato's responses
with dw correspondent terry schultz
welcome terry let's start with more
about russia's about what russia has
been asking for
well phil you know we've been hearing
these complaints from moscow for years
about how nato should not be expanding
to countries that were in the former
soviet sphere of influence so they
didn't really come as a surprise most of
them at the same time
when you see things written down when
they are delivered in the form of
proposed treaties one between the u.s
and russia and one between nato and
russia it takes on a different a
different flavor and i think it was
pretty pretty bold of president putin to
write out these these supposed treaties
and hand them over now in the midst of
such tense times
and was there an or else in this stated
or implied
i think there are tens of thousands of
or else's masked along the border with
ukraine russia again
as i mentioned it it prepared these
treaties for the first time written down
spelled out in such detail while it has
possibly more than a hundred thousand
soldiers
massing along multiple points on the
border with ukraine and i heard even as
recently as today from a nato diplomat
that despite the phone call between
presidents biden and putin despite all
the talk about
wanting to de-escalate that russia is
instead escalating that it is moving
more and more material troops and
long-term
long-term facilities into this region
keeping nato and the u.s very nervous
right so on the face of it though
amongst these demands like demanding a
veto on nato members and telling nato
where it can and can't deploy its forces
these sound like demands that moscow
expects to fail or to be rejected so can
we speculate about what president putin
really wants
well some of them are not ones that that
russia expects to fail some of them of
course are i mean one of the most um i
think outrageous ones is that it says
that nato cannot uh deploy in any sort
of resources in countries that are nato
members like the baltic states any any
country that joined after 1997 which
they did so i mean some of those
obviously are non-starters others are
actually things that nato would like to
see that the u.s would like to see um
limitations on on what kind of missiles
can be based where and used and
especially as you heard secretary
general stoltenberg say
confidence-building measures now this is
something that nato has been asking from
russia for years about more transparency
about what kind of exercises that it's
launching in countries uh on near the
border of of nato allies
in belarus
for example and russia has been simply
unresponsive to these requests from nato
so sure some of them if russia were to
undertake them with any genuine interest
would be something nato would be
interested in discussing but that
remains to be seen as i say russia has
refused to for example allow observers
to assess exercises as it is required to
do under international agreements so
there actually could be some things to
talk about that would be good for both
sides
and how have nato representatives been
responding to these demands
you heard the secretary general say um
as i just mentioned that there are
things that nato would like to talk
about at the same time there are things
there are issues such as uh giving
moscow a veto over which countries can
join nato that will never ever be
something
that can even be put on the table in any
way shape or form um russia will not
have the right to say that ukraine can't
become a nato member or certainly that
any sort of deployments must be pulled
out of of nato allies but
written into these proposed treaties are
also some measures that um could be
discussed but i just reread them before
we were coming on the air and some of
them even already exist for example that
hotlines would be set up between nato
and russia in case um to to avoid any
sort of mistakes or incidents that
already exists so some of these are kind
of puzzling to to me
meanwhile russia of course is massing
troops its own troops on its own
territory
menacingly close to ukraine which isn't
a nato member so has nato said
what these massive consequences will be
or this high price that russia will pay
if russia does in fact invade ukraine
trust me phil we ask constantly what
exactly they would do and of course
they will not divulge what they are
preparing for in case
russia were to invade ukraine i mean it
is said constantly that because ukraine
is not a nato member there's no article
5 guarantee for that country it cannot
call the nato allies to defend it in
case of further aggression in case of an
invasion by russia and ukraine is very
painfully aware of this at the same time
if russia were to step across the border
to do more than it's already done in
taking crimea ukraine's crimea region
the west could not fail to respond that
would simply be too great of of of an
aggression against
against a partner country of nato allies
of the united states so i think that
one important point is that for example
last night the european union and nato
put out statements talking about
repercussions for moscow the european
union could take could take very extreme
financial measures that could cut off
for example russian banks that would be
the most the the most instant response
that could be done by the international
community and perhaps the the one that
russia would feel uh the most keenly
nato is unlikely to mount a military
response to a russian invasion of
ukraine nonetheless most of the allies
are also members of the european union
plus the united states and they have
ways of making moscow feel pain if it
were to take this step and truly go back
into ukraine all right we shall watch
and wait for now terry thank you so much
terry schultz in brussels
you